welcome to this blitz game five minute
chess uhm Jung our penguin okay let's
see Kings Indian and grew and felt & goo
in fraud type of position yeah okay
let's see yeah I normally do this but
there are many lines Oh c6 that's not
seen too often hmm they are taking it is
a very common thats this is a very
simple way to play with oh he actually
takes with the Queen mmm I was expecting
a porn capture ok I'm going to do that
attacking the rook in the corner
yeah this is what one idea of queen bee
three sometimes you can get this funny
attack on the rookin and ask black if
this is a harmonious setup or not mostly
it isn't the only problem is that why
does delaying his development in love it
um okay so he obviously has spotted the
the Bishop c4 idea not very difficult um
however what about hmm what about what
about Queen before is a move I know it
looks strange but it keeps an eye on e 7
and the text b7 and be success is a move
that is a bit weakening so not something
that black is so enthusiastic about
maybe okay he has night d7 form c-5m or
that one young here I will move the
Queen I don't want the Queen trade I
guess or not no I don't want to go in
trade
yeah White's claim for an advantage well
justified or not I mean not saying how
much better and it's that those pawn
moves f6c 6v6 have weakened black a
little bit while my structure ping is
pretty pretty sound and by the way what
about you for here you form maybe f5 but
still still I want to do this one point
is that c5 now can be answered by g5
which definitely should be a little bit
better for me and maybe he has to go f5
hmm didn't expect that one okay let's
get it get the Queen back into them into
normal kind of lines I have oxy 8 45
maybe quid 85 was an alternative this
this is where I wanted to put it
originally but it didn't it didn't
really materialize um look q1 maybe want
to catch up a bit on the club him Jack
didn't expect that at all thought that
this would just be good for wide
Bishop a 3 now
squinty form check for bishop t to the
the pollen before
he's playing without this Bishop on g7
and I don't see how he gets it into the
game after fri make a duty 5 and before
is really just lost um yeah here d5 just
for positional advantage or grabbing the
pawn yeah come on i'm lazy here d 5 for
the wait he can go at five now yeah and
now we can play this move that was
stupid hmm ah that was a mistake that
was just bad play I shouldn't have
played t5 okay maybe here takes 92 yeah
that was a mistake really I shouldn't
have allowed that hmm 92 was my idea but
es Knight e5 maybe my g5 maybe it's the
better way to get this set up
95 i also have Quint xe5 the real issue
is this rock on 84 it looks really
pretty stupid now I should urgently put
it back on a chew
yeah my rating took some hits IAM the
last couple of games I mean I'm pretty
steadily keeping it above 2,300 recently
and even 2,400 normally was was quite
them quite reliably kept with okay going
high as he was difficult should be five
I didn't expect but I don't really know
maybe I'm still okay if it looks kind of
weird with the Lucani phones and things
like that
yeah any Knight f6 is also answered by
Bishop c5 yeah well here I can take a
fall right on a night eggs i want i
wanted to play but Queenie fire well I
cannot take I can take him theoretically
taken with the Queen but don't know this
is this is helping anything I take it
and f3 is this this is too passive I
don't know my time is it's limited time
morning
can just take c-5m or play rook e1 and I
maybe Ruby 1c5 is still hanging out so
95 Quincy five is a move if I take with
the Queen here see for at the end c4
takes be three but I can I can I can
hold it the porn at least just just in
time for that yeah now rook the eighth
hmm what is screw up maybe I can just
about who would it but the absolute best
possible outcome black forfeits on time
what is this I want two points down I
didn't even realize that I'm so in such
bad shape yeah wow this is endgame I did
screw up I mean here I should just win
but this is this is just just not not
convincing how am i winning 95k I can
play that hmm now I didn't see that one
the big point is this is the threat so
you cannot play this
check the mega fork yeah it stays a fog
even after the Queen trade so there was
the win I'm but I'm interested really in
this position which should be should be
should be good d 5 is really not really
not good you have allowing f5 here I
should be better this position is
somewhat it's this is not ammonius for
black but how exactly am I doing this
look see oneness what the what the
engine is suggesting hmm interesting the
point is that this is good for white
yeah beef is basically gone we'll see
one rook c8 so the engine siddur the new
gate we are getting the rook back yeah
here white is really just bet I am yeah
this is what i need to do after this he
gets he gets enormous counterclaim he
had better again he shouldn't take but
play F for it seems yeah it's a
difficult it's a difficult game we
should be here night and now i have to
take on c5 Queenie 5 actually wasn't
precise Quincy 7 was better and here
this is now in love from black yeah I
just thought okay I have the pawn and
well let's see if I can condemn not even
upon up I was thinking I have a porn up
huh this is a weird hallucination I was
thinking pornhub okay well then this was
total total nonsense really was actually
while we played I thought I'm just one
porn down but yeah here it hit me here
I'm two points down and just lost but at
one on time for once yeah I lost them I
spoiled some chances in this game
okay well thanks for watching